Trevor, Victor,
congratulations.
You guys have made it to
the third and final round
of this competition, and now
we're sending you to your home
forges for four grueling days
to recreate this iconic weapon
from history.
The épée-de-combat.
Gentlemen, this blade can be
seen wielded by Arya Stark
from Game of Thrones.
[laughs]
Good luck, bladesmiths,
we'll see you in four days.
It's day one, and
I'm about to start
making the épee-de-combat.
I've come to call it
the holy [bleep] sword,
because it is so
thin and so long,
it's going to be a very,
very difficult blade to make.
I've chosen 5160.
It's good, tough, spring steel.
I want to make this
blade as rigid as I can,
but still flexible.
Yeah, the wheels are turning.
They're pretty rusty,
but they're turning.
It is the end of day one.
I hit the link I was
aiming for to a point
where I say it's in good shape.
I'm hoping to be
grinding blade tomorrow.
We're here in
San Antonio, Texas.
Let's get the fire going.
I've never made
such a light sword,
so to make this as light
as it's supposed to be
is definitely a challenge.
My plan is to use the 5160
for the actual sword itself,
and then for the
pommel and the guard,
I'm gonna see if I can
bring out some Damascus
to throw my twist on it.
It's too wide, so I'm
turning it down quite a bit,
little at a time.
Now that I've got my sword
to a comfortable state,
I start cutting some pieces for
billets, three small stacks,
so I can make my
pommel, quillon,
and guard out of Damascus.
This is the start of day two.
Rolling along pretty good.
Today I'm going to start
trying to put the crease
in the back for the fullers.
I've never ground
fullers before.
It's a huge learning
curve for me,
so it's going to be critical.
I get the fuller
cut into the back,
I'm trying to grind on the front
side, and they're not working.
It's not cutting to the
depth that I wanted.
It's grinding it flat.
It's frustrating
the hell out of me.
[bleep] I've messed
up my center line.
Badly.
I've got like 6
center lines now.
I wanted to have both sides of
the fullers completed today,
and I still got to get
this blade quenched,
so I hope that I can
finish this blade.
It's day two, I'm trying to
get the Damascus forge-wielded,
sorted to shape.
This is going to
be my guard, those
are going to be my quillons.
So right now I'm just
thinning it down so they
don't have so much weight.
I have the pommel
billets, and I started
drawing out the quillons,
I think I'm happy with it.
Now that I finish up the handle
pieces, it's time to quench.
You can see my blade shaking,
I'm shaking so much right now.
This is all do or die.
Nice and straight that way,
nice and straight that way.
I left it just a
little bit thick,
so I can do all
my hollow grinds,
and then all I have left
would be the fit up,
and put a handle.
On day three, I need
to finish grinding
my fullers on both sides.
I need heat treatment, I need
to shape it into the blade
that it's going to be.
Yesterday, I failed miserably
at grinding fullers,
so today has to go
better, or I'm in trouble.
I worked my fullers down to
a point where I'm satisfied,
and I decided that
it's time to quench.
She took, I think
that's pretty good.
The épée-de-combat is
supposed to be light and fast.
And my blade turned out to be
really thin and pretty light.
I think it'll be a good blade.
Final stretch.
Still a lot to do,
and majority of day's
gonna be on the handle.
I'm going to go with some
stabilized Buckeye burl.
I have two different
tones, and it'll
give it a good two tone look.
I like it so far.
It's still a little
heavy, but it's
pieced together pretty good.
I'm finishing!
Thank God!
All right, bladesmiths.
This is the kill test.
I will take your weapon and
deliver some thrust and slashes
on our dummy from the North.
Trevor, you're up first.
You ready for this?
I'm ready.
All right, Trevor.
First up.
It is so light.
Just like a needle.
Your point here
allows for a very deep
penetration without any effort.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Good job.
All right, Victor.
Your turn.
Are you ready?
- Ready.
All right, Victor.
Let's talk about
your sword here.
It's not very light.
Overall, though, it's
pointy enough to thrust,
the edge with the weight
cuts, and it'll kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
It's time for the strength test.
To test the strength and overall
construction of your blades,
just like an ice pick, I'm
going to be chipping ice.
Trevor, you're up first.
You're ready?
I'm ready.
OK, Trevor.
You did pick up a
slight bend in your tip.
Having said that, I
mean, this thing is
so light, which is fantastic.
Thank you.
All right, Victor.
You are up.
Are you ready, sir?
Ready.
Victor, first off,
blade is same shape
as when we started out.
Tip's still there, it's fine.
Your fullers are there,
but they're not very deep.
And by not having them very
deep, this blade is very heavy.
Having said that, it's a strong
blade, it took no damage.
So well done.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths.
This is the sharpness test.
This steel can stab
and waterbag slice.
I will take your
weapon, I'm going
to test the tip by
thrusting into the cans,
and I'm going to slash the bag.
Trevor, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
All right, Trevor.
No issues at all in
stabbing the can,
and the cut with your tip on
that bag, you can see it's
a straight cut all
the way through.
Overall, sir, it'll cut.
Thank you.
All right, Victor.
Your turn.
So you ready?
Ready.
All right, Victor.
First up in the stabbing
test, on one of the thrusts,
it pushed the can in more than
penetrated all the way through,
but your edge is sharp.
On the bag, it cut cleanly
all the way through.
And more importantly, it'll cut.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
I finished my discussion
with your judges,
and they've made
their final decision.
Our new Forged in Fire
champion is Trevor.
Congratulations.
You're the new Forged
in Fire champion.
Victor, unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut
by the narrowest of margins.
And David Baker's
going to tell you why.
Victor, the épéé-de-combat
was supposed to be a lightning
fast thrusting sword.
The weight of your
blade led it to be just
a more difficult weapon to use.
That's why we're letting you go.
Victor, unfortunately,
today your blade
doesn't make the cut.
I'd like to invite you
to shake our hands,
shake your competitor's
hand, and then
please leave the forge.
This was a great experience.
And just holding my
head high, just to know
I've had this opportunity to
build this historical weapon.
Performed well, and
I'm proud of it.
First thing I do when I go
home, kiss the wife, my son,
and start forging and get
ready for my next knife show.
Trevor, congratulations.
You are our new Forged
in Fire champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
Come on forward, my friend.
Good job.
I can't believe that
I won Forged in Fire.
Feeling better than good.
The most fun I've had in years.
With the $10,000 I have,
I may buy a new sander,
but most of it will
go to my wife, though.